little guys I'm Greg and I'm John the
Black Caps is back people the black
couch has returned I've redesigned my
living room a couple of things before I
get to this video I know that III is out
right now
Briana and Dan I'm trying to get them to
come over this week hopefully by the end
of the week that way I could get some
videos up let's face it
I don't really know as much as you guys
want me to second thing this video is
called Greg Alba is dead oh boy have you
died apparently so God tell me I'm dead
oh wow is the internet death hoax about
me it goes right through your head all
these comments about beauty like dude
you made Tyrone cry Tyrone's a little
[ __ ] that's why he's a little [ __ ]
hope you're doing a reaction to this
Tyrone little [ __ ] crying with some
dumb joke I mean he called me I had to
console him yeah whatever
his own cries all the time yeah that's
over at anything rola you made Tyrone
krump time I'm gonna do we saw pepto
bismal commercial he teared up hey man
everyone can relate to stomach problems
don't don't don't judge those muscles as
strength people he's really weak on the
inside there's an earthquake that
happened in California he sent me a text
saying heard about this yes the first
thing on-screen heard about the
earthquake you okay man and I just
texted back I'm dead Tyrone he said no
and then a little bit later the next day
so you did something a little funny with
my video though I'm getting a lot of
comments and tweets and messages as if I
did something really [ __ ] up to Tyra
oh God
so let's see what you did Tyrone ease
better make me laugh and not cry like
you are you little crybaby crybaby I cry
all the time I know
[ __ ] Ryan I got some automatic focus on
that thing huh
pretty good it's great you didn't text
back is that Tyrone is every time he
says maybe like on the phone or in
person just no matter what sobs like a
little girlfriend back he was a good guy
haha I don't think - at my you liquor
all the words
not even said previously is belly from
check over laughs are you dick joke I've
cut back a little bit for the nice fire
I stopped there man places out there
nation you guys all go if you [ __ ]
kiss all your family and friends can see
better knows I'll be going ski cats real
in depressed I rode Wow boy
wow this is a major ad you should have
been you it should be every time
something happens to me I was like I
don't deserve this
hey dog a [ __ ] drink me I'm so bit
got me crying on film he texts me I'm
dead which means he's alive could me see
very album it's a Gregory Bach in you
all go let him eat them no each piece
[ __ ] average fool no no is that why I
let's go we really took the six what
these lousy caps off their oh boy whoo
that's high road that's great he took my
little joke which I thought was clever
like no one's ever said that's mean I've
never said I'm dead and then you made it
something even more
love this made it big he was reacting to
my text message yeah uh reaction text
reaction ever review yeah I'll give you
an apology right now I'm sorry to make
you cry it was a horrible joke it wasn't
funny at all
I don't know what what happens sometimes
I just I think something's funny but
it's not this is not funny you know and
death is a funny topic to me is when a
lot of death lately a lot of death which
I'm not gonna make jokes about you're
very careful in front of the camera just
yo you [ __ ] you didn't trust me I know
all about these deaths are going on and
I got some jokes but it's a little too
soon no you just you just don't have
jokes well no one knows I'm talking
about that's all over the world in
America who just really making insane
like jokes or jokes but uh yeah good I
guess so yeah I don't believe in the too
soon thing but apparently a lot of
people do so I also like 1 million
subscribe I 1 million subscribe yeah 1
million subscribers sounds nice I really
feel like anywhere I go my mom might
actually be a little proud of me
subscribe today become a reject there's
a lot of noise going on outside we're
very professional apartment yeah John's
over here his also reasons to Jerry and
social media manager bloom house calm
follow us on our social networks
Facebook Instagram Twitter if someone
hates promoting himself it's this guy oh
yeah you must be allergic
it's annoying saying all that [ __ ] like
having to subscribe go check out more
videos like the video follow us on these
social networks like it's a lot of
[ __ ] instructions for you guys so I
look good